[Music]
what if everyone on the planet said no
to their gas powered car right now and
not just cars gas dryers water heaters
gas stoves lawnmowers what if we stopped
burning fossil fuels all at once
would this make our lives that much more
inconvenient what would happen to the
climate could it help us beat global
warming this is what if and here's what
would happen if we stop burning fossil
fuels right now so you probably know
that fossil fuels are spewing carbon
dioxide into our air co2 stays in our
atmosphere and heats up the Earth's
surface the greenhouse effect the main
cause of that climate change everyone's
talking about the earth is an average of
one degree hotter than it was in the
1880s before our factories started
belching greenhouse gases into the air
doesn't seem that bad well it only took
a four degree increase to put an end to
the most recent ice age 12,000 years ago
with all our power plants cars and
appliances we humans are the main cause
of today's global warming what if we
banded together and eliminated the use
of fossil fuels once and for all would
this be the solution to climate change
want to know what life would be like if
we stopped burning fossil fuels right
now first off there would be no
transportation no cars no trains no
planes no ships nothing your local
grocery store wouldn't get fresh food
delivered for you to buy your electric
car would likely be useless to why but
just think about where your electricity
comes from did you know more than
two-thirds of the world's electricity
production comes from burning fossil
fuels so there would be no electricity
not quite with one-third of electric
power generated by renewables and
nuclear stations we wouldn't go
completely electricity free the party
would still be going strong in countries
like Costa Rica Norway and Iceland they
run almost exclusively on renewable
our so head there if you need to charge
your phone the fossil fuel industries
would cease to exist so with their five
trillion dollars of annual revenue it's
not just large energy producers like
Russian Gazprom or American ExxonMobil
who would go bankrupt millions of people
are employed in those industries who
would lose their jobs
coal miners may want to get some
training and solar panel installation
say goodbye to plastics and a lot of
your favorite gadgets since plastic is
made from oil and gas we wouldn't be
making any more new toys eliminating a
stable and cheap source of energy right
now seems a bit extreme what's more it
wouldn't solve our climate change
problem and on the short-term the global
warming we've already inflicted on our
planet is irreversible even if we stop
burning fossil fuels the earth would
continue warming up for another few
decades because of all the heat we've
already produced global temperatures
would climb finally stabilizing at a
level much higher than we've ever known
although that's far into the future the
reality is if we don't start burning
less fossil fuels now the result would
be devastating
luckily or not someday we'll run out of
non-renewable coal gas and oil anyway
are you ready to rock some solar panels
yet how do you help combat climate
change